Zombieland double tap has arrived and as
of this taping is coming in at 80% on
the tomato meter it's been nearly a
decade since the first lime peel and
movie delight at both fans and critics
and the sequel according to the critics
consensus is an enjoyable reunion that
recaptures the spirit of the original
and adds a few fun twist hello everyone
and welcome to the Rotten Tomatoes show
I am mark Ellis and I am so excited to
be talking about zombie land double tap
today we're gonna dive deep into the
film tell you all what we thought about
it and yes it is a spoiler heavy talk so
if you've not yet seen the movie you've
been warned
um we have a great panel here these are
three people that would really feel
comfortable surviving a zombie
apocalypse with so when I introduce you
please tell the audience what your
zombie land name would be starting off
with you know her from the twisted woman
CK our YouTube channel it is CK our
Chauncey K Robinson is here John see how
are you I'm good yeah I am great your
Zombieland name would be NORC
would be Newark okay North Jersey North
Jersey new art new arc Jersey all right
there we go so we define Chauncey
sitting next to her on her left is he
probably knows the month day and year of
the original Zombieland released
actually I don't but I know it was 2009
October 2nd October manse is here and
your zombie land my zombie land nickname
I am very proud to say would be
Philadelphia okay oh well good we're
picking up you know to our driver door
and last but certainly not least a
returning favorite from Rotten Tomatoes
mr. Alex BOE is here hey Alex Here I am
from San Jose which is probably about a
30 hour drive yeah yeah cross yeah it's
about 3,000 miles yeah because I've made
the drive from Williamsburg Virginia I'm
Alice so Williams very first question
for the panel of great cities that we
have before us is simply is the movie
fresh is the movie rotten Johnson start
with you is this a fresh two Rotten
movie I think it's definitely fresh it
expands the universe and but it doesn't
get away from the core characters that
we love which I really appreciate it
very well said now Alex Bo San Jose are
you going to ratify the
I'm gonna say rotten what I expected
nothing and I was still disappointed get
these West Coast crossbows from this
understand it seems like you're going
for it I'm going fresh I'm going fresh
with Newark here because I thought that
the movie just recaptured the spirit and
the fun of the original film and it
didn't really expand on it enough but
we'll get to that but I still had a
great time just like I did with the
first book yeah I'm going first as well
I didn't think it was quite as good as
the first one but I thoroughly enjoyed
myself and there's a reason why they
call them the Sharks in San Jose the
movie but Scott I want to kick off with
you the first topic because like any
time a sequel comes out you have two
questions that are asked as one does it
live up to the original and number two
was it worth the wait we've been waiting
10 years for this movie
okay well out there the second question
first was it worth the wait I've loved
the first movie but I don't know if I
was waiting for a sequel it's not wasn't
a movie where there's a man let's go two
or three years let's have a zombie land
sequel but I still had fun with it and
here we are ten years later I would say
that the movie it it's as good as the
original for what it does well with the
chemistry with the fun but sort of the
in joke moments it doesn't really expand
on it it doesn't capitalize it doesn't
grow from the first movie but I still
had just as much fun as the original
House was that your issue is that it
does not grow from the original at all I
would that's not my issue I would agree
with Scott words like asking me well I
wasn't worth the wait they don't imply I
was waiting for a sequel in the first
place like the first ones great it's
fine but like beyond now it's like
awesome let's move on to or let's do
something else
whereas this one yeah it's like the
issue for me was most a movie they spend
separated again and it's like I've
already seen that movie is called the
zombie land one I just wanted them throw
tie it together and sort of kicking ass
but it's that they're being constant
separated by these really specious
reasons I felt so more United crew is
what you were kind of you got a little
bit of that and the
ten minutes and then they do started
going off on their own again yeah it's
on see when I like to sit if you ask the
question was the movie worth the wait I
I think we can all agree like we weren't
just sitting by the computer waiting for
the news to be announced but I think
this movie had fun with that it started
out light and fluffy it made a joke that
there's so many more zombie options that
you have now and then we rip into
Metallica so I think the white and
fluffiness actually helped the movie
yeah I thought it I mean I kind of
considered it a feel-good zombie picture
that's the thing but I think that
totally is what it was and I think it
was very aware of itself that had been
so long they were like yeah we're back
and we know there's been so much other
stuff but that's okay cuz you know you
love zombie land and I I enjoyed it I
thought it was I I actually think it's
better than the previous one okay then
again I you know I didn't watch it in
2009 when first one came Ike and I
watched it like maybe in the last few
years I wasn't like anticipating
anything and then I actually like that
they expanded it because I didn't like
all the characters in the first one so
it was good to kind of have a different
dynamic going on even though I
appreciate it the love of the core for
it it had you know had family vibe in
the locations we go to I did have a lot
of fun watching this movie and it has
been 10 years and you really feel the
weight when you look at the actors
resumes I mean I'm a stone now has an
Oscar you know you you see everything
that's done but it felt like as soon as
this movie started we all just settled
right back into zombie land from 2009
big time that's that's what I loved
about the film the most is that here you
have Emma Stone Oscar winner for lala
land no there is barrier one segment
before you reference did you know what
that is but what lucky did fit right
back into that role of Wichita great
chemistry with Jesse Eisenberg who you
know and and to think about Jesse
Eisenberg Oscar nominee he created
Facebook as Mark Zuckerberg and the
social network I but everyone you know
what he Harrelson hasn't changed at all
it's the original film I mean he hasn't
changed his look at all like 20 years
but yeah that family vibe that you were
talking about the heart the chemistry
even though they were separate
which I think you know you have to
change it up a little bit I thought the
addition of the newer characters also
added to a different sort of chemistry
yeah and I wanted to move into that for
our next topic Alex because when you
talk about a chemistry that these four
have some of the the critics have been
saying that they didn't really respond
to the new characters that were
introduced that it did take away from
the core for a little bit like you had
some what I thought were fun cameos from
Luke Wilson Thomas Middleditch I thought
rosario Dawson was a great addition to
the cast your feelings on the newcomers
yeah I would agree rosario Dawson was a
pretty fleshed out character she had a
lot going on there Zoey Dutch character
Madison Madison yes who spent ten years
in a freezer yeah I did not buy at all
you've been talking about how great
Zoe Dutch was in the role I guess she is
but she's great at playing like a [ __ ]
character I just could not Wow yeah I
could not stand sail with that dude
introduced for forever going presence
character that uh-oh Berkley I was like
I was confused as to how any of these
characters survived 10 years 15 years
into a zombie about it zombie movie it's
not a comedy but what's bad about well
what's pretty about zombie land one is
like you have a guy who's like neurotic
and very rules focus lately right and
you could buy but you buy that he can
survive in this world apocalypse
sitting with Tallahassee stay with these
two characters and when they kind of
come together they work really well
whereas these two other characters is
hard for me to buy them in like in our
own reality I can understand that at
that point because it's like if I'm
watching Walking Dead
Jhansi and then somebody's been living
in a Pinkberry freezer for ten years
seems like a stretch but for the tone of
Zombieland i thought particularly Zoey's
character stole a lot of scenes I loved
Madison I thought she was hilarious and
not just because of the way she played
the part but because it was actually a
very strong kind of character just a
different kind of strong were used to
with like she knew what she wanted as
soon as she wanted sex like I have a
mission I'm gonna do I'm gonna bite the
bullet in through the old guy if you
don't want to do it she was very direct
and I just thought she was a lot of fun
and I thought it was a good addition to
yeah in the body
as well Rosaria dolphin because it was
you know she had a strong this to her
and it was very different kind of women
characters which I appreciate we do have
to talk about Rosario Dawson's character
Nevada Scott it was it was such a breath
of fresh air seeing her near Graceland
not exactly in Graceland but at
Graceland at Jason and she for my
money's the best monster truck driver
I've seen since gravedigger she is
terrific in this film you know she's a
big John Ruth in any way but you could
tell that she was having a lot of fun
great chemistry especially with Woody
Harrelson I really thought that that in
terms of adding new characters to this
movie she was a worthy addition to the
zombie land franchise yeah John see I
mean it for all the the coupling that
could have gone on in this movie I was
rooting for Azaria and woody them at
each other and just her being there and
like his love for Elvis and her love for
Elvis like I want to know the back story
of how she ended up there like why that
you know she had the same kind of vibe
that he did and they just like clicked
immediately didn't take long I totally
believed the hook-up I guess people you
know it's Dom being time so you know
they're looking for love so he found it
with him and it was just awesome yeah
Alex we're gonna talk about our zombie
when future in a little bit here but I
kind of like the idea of a Nevada
prequel Yeah right talk about how she
got the hotel of right right was like
did she like was it a heist where she
went to Graceland grabbed all the Elvis
stuff and why you brought it back over
there you know but yeah I would agree
like out of all the new characters what
she brought out of what he houses
character and how she juice were like
the nexus point where you could bring in
Thomas Middleditch and Luke Wilson I'm
gonna just I'm gonna keep the the front
row going with the with the Zombieland
nicknames San Jose I will I do agree
that that the one flaw of the film about
the characters being separate is that
when Abigail Breslin has Little Rock was
separated from the rest of the core
group because she hooked up with with
Berkeley that was the weakest link of
the film was was her storyline with
Berkeley it just it just didn't move the
story along it didn't have it didn't
resonate nearly as much with me as the
other scenes with the other care like
what I thought was like how interesting
like
little rocks aren't exactly interesting
it's like yes you would you would walk
the Panda [ __ ] with someone her own age
and what if that guy that she hooked up
with his like it was actually really
interesting like the whole time you're
kind of way for them to split up because
like this guy's yeah right totally so
but what if there's a it sounds like
what it be is actually better off with
these dudes but I also know I have a
long record like if you're really gonna
see the like how much time has passed
I mean abigail breslin has you know she
definitely has matured into a young
woman and and you know you're seeing her
completely different whereas the other
characters look pretty much the same so
I feel like you could have had you could
have done more with that and I felt like
her character's story line was the
weakest link in the film but I still
liked the film yeah with a little
contrived but it was because they needed
to get them to go on a road trip but not
we would have been in the white house
the whole time I enjoy but I actually
thought it was it made sense that she'd
hook up with a really crappy guy because
she hasn't been with anyone for so long
it's like well this guy is kind of cute
rips off Bob Dylan and like I thought
that joke was so good and it does make
it more convenient for the movie that we
all are rooting against this
relationship or for back regardless of
what people may say about the Thomas
Middleditch or the Luke Wilson cameo
think we can all agree that kill Steen
was one of the best in the movie so I
want to talk about some of y'all's
favorite scenes if you have any Chauncey
I wrap my brain kick me off with one of
your favorite scenes from Jean doing a
double time well definitely that killed
scene that was amazing I liked a lot of
the White House antics and then the Bill
Murray scene at the end the after
credits kind of Marvel style like people
were getting up but it's like wow
there's something else going on it was
an action scene I really thought that
was hilarious yeah people and I know
that all of us here you know you've been
in that junket style situation umber of
times into this so to see that Lampoon I
don't know how people do not work in the
industry are gonna receive that but Bill
Murray's in it so I'm pretty sure
they're gonna watch well III just
thought that they keep the Bill Murray
joke
gag the running joke you're owing and it
does have a great payoff that's nothing
one of the best scenes in terms of like
zombie kills I thought the zombie kill
of the year with the
guy on the farm and the big tractor you
know much about the the zombie with it
with this machine you know and just in
the Leaning Tower of Pisa house you got
all of the weenies come on chance eh you
gotta love it
so what else what else stuck out to you
it's like oh okay well that's the
redeemable quality about the movie yeah
I think the introduction of Thomas
Middleditch and Luke Wilson were great
actually I think those twenty-five
minutes where they're in the movie
that's like really thank you yeah like a
really came to life they're like even
like the way the camera would swoop
around as they're being chased around by
the zombie version it's like that was
like beautiful camerawork I was like
this is kind of what I was hoping for
throughout the whole movie but I would
also agree with the the junket massacre
at the end whereas like every gone
through that you know it could be kind
of numbing on both sides of the camera
on both sides so like this scene this
sort of chaos brought from in pretty
good a quick sidebar so what was the
better Bill Murray scene was it the Bill
Murray scene from the first nandi land
or was it this Bill Murray yes what
first one I'm going I didn't expect this
about the first unexpected right I
thought okay he's done you know he got
married you know and I love the
reference of getting married yeah
talking about you know a chest
kotsenburg in his neurotic way but I
didn't expect that that that code has
seen that the bonus scene at all and it
was it was a great surprise and also
seeing here my friend Josh Horowitz you
know it turned into a zombie girlfriend
Grace Randolph was was in the post
credit thing oh yeah yeah yeah no that
was I thought that was it died and
listen the the scene with with the
Thomas Middleditch and and Luke Wilson
as a Flagstaff and Albuquerque
basically playing doppelgangers mirror
versions of Jesse Eisenberg and Woody
Harrelson that that scene alone makes
the movie worth seeing that scene alone
tops the original those 25 minutes is is
better than the whole original film that
boot scene was so inspired it was so
much fun
it was so different and it was the peak
of the film and what we see in this
movie is this new community Babylon and
so if we have Babylon then there's
probably other communities like this and
I'm pretty sure we didn't kill all the
zombies in this post-apocalyptic
landscape so Chauncey what could be next
for the zombie land franchise are we
done after this or do you think that
there's room for another movie Amazon
had a pilot in 2013 do we maybe go back
to a streaming service where should
sandy land go well I'd like another
movie maybe you know one of the couples
I know this gets like so cliche but one
of them is having a baby or something
try to raise a kid in the zombie
apocalypse and what I think that would
be kind of interesting in a very cuz
we've seen one of the great things about
the franchise is that it's very aware of
itself you know it's very meta it makes
Joseph talk it talked about The Walking
Dead so it's like it's very aware that
it might do a lot of the cliched so it
would be nice to do another movie like
that I wouldn't want a series because I
feel like we had a series that was very
similar to what they would be which is
the nation
I thought the nation was very similar to
them in the same vein as which was had
the comedy house outlandish news so we
kind of do that already
Alex is there any room for redemption
possibly with another zombie land or are
you come on out I do like the idea ruben
fleischer and Jesse Eisenberg did a AMA
on reddit like yesterday talking about
like one question was so zombie alien 3
and 2029 like that's the idea
I like this it's like the up series or
like you know before sunrise or sunset
that's every 10 year to come back and
you know you see where these characters
are and the way it is meta right so like
in the next 10 years they couldn't score
a comment on where does ami genre has
gone they just keep on doing that and we
could see maybe a child pop up somewhere
in there Scott here's what I want to see
in Zombieland the other three cities on
the panel you know I thought zombie land
double tap it was a worthy sequel not a
soup not necessarily a superior one it I
loved it for what it was okay but if
you're going to do a zombie Land 3 just
go for it really just pull out all the
stops and go for it now when I think of
like the great movie sequels of all time
I mean sure there's there's Godfather -
there's star trek through the rat the
cons favorite of the
I listen nothing is better than gremlins
- I knew your grants - gremlins - was so
great because it was a spoof of the
original movie it made fun of the
original film it pulled out all the
stops if you've never seen gremlins -
which came out July 2nd 1990 the same
day as Dick Tracy it is a superior
sequel in every sense of the word and it
just throws a wild wacky crazy a really
awesome sequel so that's what I want to
see for zombie when Anthony just just go
for it there was a little bit of meta
stuff you know like that there was a
joke about Walking Dead but really just
have fun with it maybe zombie land 3 is
it is about the filming of zombie land 3
that is that is meta on top of meta
that's like that's a meta sandwich and
we might be here for more zombie win in
some capacity is the consensus that I'm
getting from my panel who by the way
today was terrific thank you to my
guests Scott Chauncey and Alex for
joining me here today to talk about
zombie land double tap and I would
remind everybody out there watching
right now we have some really good news
here rotten tomato if we have our first
book Rotten movies we love these are
movies that are green on the spectrum so
technically they're rotten according to
tomato meter but we love them all just
the same stepbrothers made the cover
Spaceballs that's sitting there at 59%
there's so many fun rotten movies and
you can check them all out in this book
there's a hundred one of them as a
matter of fact so get the book to pay
with your friends that's what we like
doing around these parts thanks so much
for tuning in today subscribe right here
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
to give you an alert every time we have
a new rotten tomatoes dope coming out
thanks so much we'll see you next time
[Music]